when we walked through that curtain when
we could actually be ourselves that is
what truly made the bella twins even
though bree and i have always been such
open books we just have never really
told our story and our journey he and i
were raised that when there's conflict
you settle it in an aggressive way nikki
and brie go all the way back to the
beginning during a e's biography wwe
legends this sunday sharing what it was
like growing up with a drug addicted
father nikki also reveals the guilt she
feels for being a reason her parents
split during my childhood it was very
difficult and i felt like as a young
girl i was already a woman and i knew
what my mom deserved and it wasn't in
the marriage that she was in
and at 15 years old i felt that i had to
be at that moment the ring leader of the
household i refused to come home unless
he was gone and i left my mom no choice
and it wasn't choice she wanted at the
time but i know it's a choice that
obviously she's extremely grateful for
and also my father because i think
you know he fell into a deeper
like
darker place after that but then he had
this reborn too and sometimes which is
hard rebirth yeah
this in-depth look at the 38-year-old
twin story also dives into nicki's
sexual assault how the ladies have made
the wwe a better place for women
motherhood and one of their first jobs
it's funny because
it's not like we set out to be hooter
girls but what happened is we moved to
san diego they found us it found us the
owl found us we moved to san diego and
we're like we're 18. we need to make
some cash and how do we do this and
there she was
hooters and her orange glory yeah we
actually have our 20-year hooters
reunion
um in august august
i mean we didn't even go to our high
school 20-year reunion but we're making
our hooters one that's for sure yes so
we're super excited but um you know what
it taught us you have to keep men in
check
very quickly at a young age we just
really
just grew a really strong backbone i
remember when jessica simpson necklace
had the reality show and jessica simpson
dissed tutor girls and we all were like
oh how dare you dare her does she know
how hard we work little girls and women
were inspired by us they were empowered
by us nikki credits her ex-fiance john
cena for helping her get back into the
ring after she broke her neck in 2015.
she also opens up about their public
breakup i think a lot of women get into
that situation and it's like but i love
this person but i don't know if it's
right for my life
and and that's the hard thing about life
is we meet amazing people but sometimes
we're just meant to live a different
life i kept praying so hard and then i
just got this feeling so deep in my gut
of like
i need to walk away
and
i no one thought i would but it was
hitting me so hard i just knew that i
didn't want to bring a child into a
relationship that i didn't know if this
life was right for them
and i went with it and then arthur came
waltzing into my life
and now i have mateo and this is when i
know
how god is good and
believing your gut and your intuition
and falling through that good things
happen
as for nikki and artem's upcoming fall
nuptials we're still planning we are
just you know um
trying to figure out this whole family
thing with artem so
um praying that we could get artem's
family either you know hopefully to
america soon
[Music]
you